attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
salut c'est fou qu'on se croise là je
viens de te voir
moi ça fait cinq minutes que je te lui
mais je regarde ailleurs pourquoi tu
viens de me parler ben moi je suis venu
parce que comme je suppose que je vais
beaucoup mieux que toi ça me faisait
plaisir de narnia
je présente inès la nouvelle de bien à 7
à 9
quand je t'ai vu avec elle j'ai cru que
c'était une escorte à savoir nager 10 à
ses toiles à celui qui l'a quittée comme
une merde
bah oui c'est moi tu as l'air d'aller
beaucoup mieux je suis presque déçu est
donc ressorti ensemble ouais c'est bien
parti
alors je tombe sur des connards qui
voyagent et ce mec-là il était gentil
alors je précise que je voulais bien de
cannes haussière s'est senti c'est quand
même un droit qu'on s'est vus bas
c'était si quand je suis venu récupérer
mes affaires
[ __ ] et comme une merde non jour des
chiens bon quand tu m'as quitté un cap
région contre limes et puis depuis hier
tout est bon que tu la quittes et était
trop gentil ça m'exaspère et à force 3
ans était devenu la routine
et puis bosser tout le temps ouais enfin
moi ça m'arrange comme ça je pourrais
avoir des prêtres mes copines c'est la
porte est fait pour avoir 7 6 face à
témoin soit j'étais triste et puis à
mettre ma vigne entrants et sa technique
de l'animal blessé ça c'est toujours
plus facile à capturer et si je reviens
pour noms tombent pas non non non
franchement nous deux c'était c'était
inespéré
on pourrait aller boire un verre tous
les deux bien tôt franchement je vois
pas l'intérêt
bon tu veux juste que j'ai des
sentiments qui commencent à revenir pour
toi là je fais un grand sourire mais je
crois que je vais aller pleurer sur
trottoir salut salut c'est fou comme un
corps gras son ex par hasard
ah non c'est pas fou mais non c'était
fait exprès si imbriqués bien prendre
son café ici tous les matins pour la
faire chic un peu je voulais qu'ils
voient tous les deux mais ça a bien
marché
turbo un truc
[Musique]